now let's get back to that story of one
first responder still dealing with the
impacts of september 11th
stephen hess was working as an fdny ems
tech on september 11th he raced to lower
manhattan with tens of thousands of
first responders i was there the day of
but then
i spent more time
at the landfill in staten island i had a
cough almost right away the following
years he suffered several devastating
health issues breathing problems
advanced stage lupus multiple back
surgeries and mental health problems it
took me five years to come to therapy it
was working
but i had long periods of wishing i
never woke up in the morning
and then it actually contemplated
suicide because
between the pain from the lupus the
breathing
new patients who have never been treated
are still coming in every week according
to dr sandra lowe medical director of
the world trade center mental health
program at mount sinai she says 9 11
anniversary reactions are also common we
started to to hear about people having
an exacerbation of their symptoms more
nightmares or feeling more on edge the
middle of august
i started getting anxiety and the stress
and even this morning i was like
contemplating canceling this and then i
thought
you know if this can help one other
person
hess credits his treatment at the sinai
program as well as his family for their
tremendous support he hopes others reach
out for help if they need it michael
george cbs news new york